livestock genitalia livestock genocide
oh yeah never you like a chicken dad
that's a third date food we know from
the blockers trailer that you guys crack
the emoji code in order to decipher your
children's nefarious plan and teenage
emoji eggplants are dicks are we and
this thing is y'all squeeze we sourced
fan questions so we're gonna translate
them from emoji into the actual question
I'm ready starting with a pretty easy
one I know this mm-hmm are you a cat or
a dog I was gonna go dog wandering all
dirty that's foul that's cool I am a cat
person probably but I have three dogs
this one we're gonna start to escalate
who was your first kiss yes my wife 12
years ago I was 28 at the time saved
myself and it was worth it okay this one
is a little tricky but I'm curious to
see what we will make of it
three people are going to the airport
and the question mark is just
inflectional you with me which of this I
think always a woman is the best wingman
you
with no you do that I just chugged 240
with my I'm a team player I hope you
guys are noticing my slide plan just to
get Leslie closer to me so that we can
be a best friend
I am thumbs down to dinner tonight
oh what's the one food you don't eat on
a date those are both amazing guesses
it's actually not but what is the one
food you don't need on a date garlic do
you think yeah livestock genitalia
livestock sanitary oh yeah never you
like a chicken yeah that's a third day
food that actually leads us to the
actual question what was your worst date
oh it's so good no I'm the opposite I
don't like that yeah this one is getting
a little bit more complicated too cool
kids diary we were cool Gary you looked
at my diary
now I'm texting you your pieces that's
awesome I'm gonna leave it's not did
your kids teach you to read emojis that
actually makes I think I send really
weird messages because I don't know what
any of the emojis where's ah bears
where's bears koalas that is literally
the question and it's my favorite joke I
said that we got some Wonders wrote
koala the answers yes praise Peru movie
hilarity please don't tell my family I
did this oh you can't yeah oh honey this
is you see you in China to be Robin
[Music]
which movie character would you want to
be your mom Oh throw mama from the Train
is there a movie character you would
want to be your mom no my mom's saying I
would want me ruining that well--there's
hold on your mom's a wonderful woman but
there's a movie character who's better
than your mom no no though surely there
must be there isn't no Carroll scene is
a saint so back to emoji talk did you go
to your prom not only did I go I hooked
up so you went when you were 28 with
your wife remember okay this one's a
little more complicated what's my
favorite dirty line from a movie that's
super close answer that first ah matrix
sucks for your virgin when he minis get
this back wax what's your favorite are
edit comedy Oh Midnight Run blockers
comedy of all time I'm gonna choose and
I will no longer be answering mm I'm
embarrassed because someone's yelling at
me movie speak yes
there's a lot of stuff that's been done
to my admittance
it's kind of my deal okay what else can
we do - exactly did we PC blockers do
lockers - ugly bit boogaloo John you're
going to dip your penis and honey and
fire ants are gonna fight it for the
next two days I'll try the push for CGI
but no just won't seem real it won't
seem really really I can think of no
better note to leave it on than
flesh-eating fire penis ants
congratulations you've won the game with
such support good at this game bad at
high fires is there emoji for that one
great thanks so much the cast of
blockers make sure to check out the
movie on April 6 if you want to see us
hanging out with other celebrities and
puppies click here which you do so click
and as always please like share
subscribe and be nice to each other